à compter de ce mercredi matin la
pologne ne pourra plus compter sur le
gaz russe une décision prise par gazprom
mardi soir qui devancent les autorités
polonaises elle compte et ne pas
renouveler le contrat avec le géant
gazier russe à la fin de l'année un
contrat qui permettait aux pays
d'importer jusqu'à 10 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz russe par an soit
environ la moitié de tous ses besoins le
premier ministre polonais veut se
montrer rassurant
nos stockages de gaz sont plaints à 76%
il s'agit d'un taux de remplissage élevé
bien supérieur à celui de la plupart des
pays européens
ils pourront puiser dans nos ressources
et obtenir du gaz depuis d'autres
sources
pourquoi fermer le robinet du gaz à la
pologne car varsovie refuse la nouvelle
procédure de paiement établi par le
kremlin depuis l'instauration des
sanctions contre la russie elle oblige
désormais les pays de l'union européenne
de pays en roubles leur
approvisionnement en gaz des nouvelles
modalités contestées par la bulgarie qui
se voit elle aussi privée de gaz russe à
partir de mercredi une surprise pour ce
pays traditionnellement proche de moscou
c'est une annonce surprenante surtout
parce que depuis le début de la guerre
en ukraine la bulgarie et c'est vraiment
de ménager le grand frère russe
et la russie la russie de vladimir
poutine et se garde bien par exemple de
livrer des l'armement à l'ukraine le
gouvernement bulgare a annoncé
entreprendre des démarches pour trouver
des alternatives au gaz russe et gérer
ainsi la situation la part du gaz dans
le mix énergétique du pays est moins
importante que le charbon mais il
provient à 90% de russie